[Musique]
ce matin une marée de policiers devant
la cathédrale saint patrick pour rendre
hommage à l'un des leurs cela fait une
semaine que le nypd la police de new
york est en deuil
vendredi dernier c'était les funérailles
de jason rivera 22 ans les deux
policiers ont été tués par balle après
avoir répondu à un appel de détresse du
9-1-1
il aller au secours d'une mère qui avait
eu une altercation avec son fils
c'est new york contre ces tueurs et nous
n'allons pas perdre dit le nouveau maire
eric adams lui même ancien policier
leur mort a provoqué une véritable onde
de choc chez les policiers ces jeunes
faisait partie de la relève
je me sens très mal dit qu'ils faisaient
là en tant qu ancien policier c'est une
partie de moi qui est parti avec eux
en deux ans le nombre d'incidents
impliquant les armes à feu a doublé à
new york dans les quartiers de brooklyn
harlem les armes circulent impunément
[Applaudissements]
les gens fin dit il n'y a plus de
travail c'est le bordel
la pandémie a mis les gens dans un état
de désespoir et y commettent des actes
désespérés dieter
et l'hiver rude cette année ne semble
pas avoir refroidi les esprits
la pandémie a vraiment exacerbé les
problèmes dit il il ya beaucoup de
frustration
les gens ont perdu leur emploi certains
se sont fait évincé de chez eux en plus
de l'inflation tout cela est stressant
sur soi et ce stress manifestent dans la
rue à harlem durant notre tournage un
homme et blessé par balle en plein après
midi il succombera plus tard à ses
blessures
les armes entrent dans la ville en grand
nombre nous dit aïcha ses coûts qui
dirige l'organisme suite conneries 0,6
parfois ils échangent annexe boxe contre
une arme les jeunes peuvent même
commander des pièces en ligne et
construire une arme à feu de leur sous
sol
on essaie de les récupérer avant que la
rue ne s'en chargent dit elle oui la
ramène à
notre rôle c'est d'intervenir dans la
rue dit elle est hantée une désescalade
de la violence
et les attaques peuvent provenir de
n'importe où et n'importe quand
les gens qui mentent avec moi ils disent
on prend vont pas prendre le plus le
sens plus parce qu'ils ont peur
lundi dans le quartier de brooklyn un
autre affrontement dans un centre
commercial
oui
le maire promet d'augmenter les
ressources policières pour combattre la
violence oui donc
oui
nous ne pensons pas en termes de
renforcement policiers 10,9
les gens vivent de la détresse dit-il en
ajoutant des policiers on rend la
situation encore moins sécuritaire et
plus violente est pour beaucoup ce qu'il
ya de violents aussi c'est la levée du
moratoire sur les expulsions de
locataires ya deux semaines deux cent
mille personnes risquent de se retrouver
sans abri
[Musique]
si tu n'as pas à manger dit-elle en plus
si tu perds ton logement et avec les
problèmes de santé mentale tu perds
espoir son aile il faut investir dans la
prévention
même si cette recrudescence de la
violence n'atteint pas les proportions
de celle des années 80 bien des new york
et craignent qu'elle soit là pour rester
ici assez bonne figure qui sera du
canada new york